Narrator:
Tonight on "Shark Tank"...
Both: Who wants a piece
of Surprise Cake?
Essentially, it lets you
stick your phone anywhere.
There was nothing more that I
wanted to be ‐‐ an entrepreneur.
[ Rapping ] ♪ Sharks,
give the kid a chance ♪
You have a winner
on your hands.
Break down the numbers.
$10,000 in sales.
That's it?
Something's not adding up.
Your sales suck.
I came with a very,
very fair offer.
Are you crazy?
Another bad idea, but...
Another really bad idea.
What happened to "The customer
is always right," Mark?
Yeah, that's wrong.
Don't be a chicken.
Oooooh.
I'm just trying to think of
how I could outwit
these two other Sharks.
I don't have to prove myself.
Bwuah‐ha‐ha‐ha‐ha!
No!
♪♪
Narrator: First into the Tank
is a modern way
to bring a little spice
into your life.
♪♪
Hey, Sharks.
I'm Khasha Touloei.
And I'm Maynard Okereke.
We're from
Los Angeles, California,
and we're asking
for $250,000
in return for 20% equity
in our company, JADA Spices.
Can you believe
we're still cooking up
some of our favorite dishes
with the same basic salts
we've been using since
the days of the caveman?
Since caveman times,
the only evolution in seasoning
has been the addition
of unhealthy ingredients,
like MSG, animal byproducts,
and higher sodium levels.
But just like humans
have changed over time,
the way we season our foods
has also evolved.
Introducing the latest
evolution in seasoning...
[ Laughter ]
Both: Vegan chicken salt!
Whoa.
Touloei: Vegan chicken salt
is a turmeric‐based,
all‐purpose seasoning
that enhances the flavor
of any dish
while providing incredible
health benefits.
Are you trying
to eat healthier,
but your vegan chili recipe
keeps turning out bland?
Throw some
chicken salt on it.
Are you tired of the
same old buttered popcorn?
Throw some
chicken salt on it.
People love our seasoning
as a healthy alternative
to basic table salt,
and vegans especially love it
as a healthy substitute
to chicken bouillon.
We've also expanded our line
to include additional flavors,
such as reduced sodium,
lime, red pepper, barbecue,
and our new, innovative
product, turmeric salt.
Well, hold on.
JADA Spices is more than
just a seasoning company.
We're providing consumers
with healthy and
plant‐based products,
including a new
plant‐based chicken
that's gonna take the evolution
of food to the next level.
So, help us be a part of
mankind's greatest evolution
and take a leap
out of the Stone Age
by giving every kitchen the
ability to cook up healthy meals
without compromising
flavor.
So, come on, Sharks ‐‐
don't be a chicken.
Both: Who's ready
to try some samples?
‐We are.
‐I'm starving.
‐We can try.
‐Okay, so, what do we have?
So, you'll notice
right there in front of you,
we have six of our SKUs ‐‐
five of our
chicken salt flavors
and our turmeric
salt seasoning.
You have some French fries,
and you have a skewer
that has avocados,
tomatoes, and cucumbers,
and you also have
some popcorn there.
People love using our seasoning
as a popcorn seasoning.
Is this your
meatless chicken?
That is our chicken, yes.
That's your product?
Yes.
What is a
plant‐based chicken?
I would have no idea
what that is.
So, currently
on the market,
there are some
plant‐based chickens.
They all have soy.
They all have high sodium.
They all need
to be refrigerated.
They all have a whole
bunch of ingredients
that I can't pronounce.
We have created
this plant‐based chicken.
It doesn't need
to be refrigerated.
You're able to mold it
into any shape.
You can make it a nugget.
So it comes like
ground chicken, almost?
Or how does it come?
It comes in a packet.
It comes in a mix.
So it comes
as a dry powder
and you add oil and water to it
to create the paste?
That's why it doesn't
have to be refrigerated.
What?
Exactly.
All you have is a package
with our dry mix,
and then you just add
3/4 cup of water...
And it turns into chicken?
...and a tablespoon of oil.
That's it?
Yes.
Now, how many calories
is in a patty?
Per serving, you're getting
20 grams of protein.
You're getting
no cholesterol, no sugar.
You're getting 120 calories,
and, furthermore, you're
getting very low sodium.
What's in the chicken?
So, it's a very,
very clean recipe, okay?
We have like
seven ingredients.
The protein is from textured
wheat protein and pea protein.
The fiber is
from pea fiber.
A lot of vegans lack B12.
We have B12 in there.
That chicken's really good.
This chicken's really good.
Appreciate that.
Thank you, thank you.
Let me tell you guys ‐‐
it tastes exactly like chicken.
Greiner:
What's your background?
So, we met in college
at University of Washington,
and it was always our goal
to start a business together.
I'm first‐generation here
to the country.
My mom's side's from Cameroon.
My dad's side is from Nigeria.
They immigrated here
to the U. S.,
and all my life, I watched
my parents grind and hustle
just to make ends meet
and put foods on our plate.
I graduated high school
the top of my class.
I got a full‐ride scholarship
to the University of Washington.
I studied civil and
environmental engineering,
but it just
wasn't my passion.
I was a creative at heart.
Music was always
something I loved,
and so I left engineering,
and I went down to Los Angeles
to pursue music.
And I work right now
as a science communicator.
I actually have a platform
called Hip Hop Science,
where I utilize my
background in civil and
environmental engineering
and my passion for
hip hop, pop culture
to educate people on different
complex scientific subjects.
So, I was born in Iran.
I spent my younger years
in England and Australia.
My dad finally
caught a break,
and we moved to the States,
and he got a job at Boeing.
And unfortunately, my father
developed multiple sclerosis.
Ohh.
And within that year,
he became quadriplegic.
Oh, my gosh.
The following year, I went
to University of Washington.
I had to work full time
in order to support my family
and support myself.
I worked cleaning floors.
When I was at
University of Washington,
there was nothing more that I
wanted to be ‐‐ an entrepreneur.
But just with a lack
of security growing up,
I picked a secure field,
and I pursued medicine.
When I got into medical
school, they told me,
"Look, Khasha, there's no way
you're getting into dermatology.
Your grades
aren't good enough.
Your board scores
aren't good enough."
And I wasn't gonna let these
dream‐killers kill my dream,
and, basically, I just
outworked everybody.
So you got into derma‐‐
I got into dermatology.
Wow.
John: Good for you.
So, are you a doctor now?
Are you practicing ‐‐
I'm a dermatologist
right now.
Chicken salt's a big
phenomenon in Australia.
When you go to a
restaurant, there's salt,
pepper, chicken salt.
Everyone uses chicken salt.
So we took the chicken salt
from Australia,
we made it vegan,
we got rid of the chicken stock,
we got rid of the MSG,
and we lowered the sodium.
What's your average selling
price and your average cost?
Yeah, so,
it costs us 80 cents
to make one of those landed
in our warehouse.
In retail,
we sell at $4.99.
Wow.
On Amazon,
we're at $8.99,
So we're the number‐one‐selling
seasoned salt
on Amazon
numerous times.
Is that right?
We're outselling Lawry's.
At a three‐times‐higher
price point than Lawry's.
We did $319,000 last year,
with a $60,000
in EBITDA.
What about this year?
What are you gonna do this year?
We're projected to do
$500,000 this year.
And furthermore,
I want to emphasize ‐‐
we're not just
a seasoning company.
We're really excited about
this plant‐based chicken.
We think it's gonna
change the game.
Greiner: Bingo.
That's what I want
to ask you about.
Okay, so,
for me, personally,
I'm not as interested
in the salt.
Okereke: Mm‐hmm.
What I find
exceptionally different ‐‐
that patty tasted
really good.
Mm‐hmm.
Thank you.
So how much of that is going
to be your plan going forward?
Chicken is ready to launch.
We've been R&Ding it
for the last couple months.
The recipe's finished.
The ingredients
have been sourced.
We are ready to go.
You both have full‐time jobs.
How are you doing all that?
No, we do this
both full time.
Like, trust me,
Khasha and I put all ‐‐
He's a doctor.
He's a dermatologist.
And I run
my own business.
I'm an independent contractor,
so I put my time as needed.
My dream is to
pursue this full time.
I work on this
before I get to work,
during lunch,
between patients,
in the evening,
and on the weekends.
Khasha's the only one
that could go from doing
Good for you.
a skin cancer removal to
negotiating a distributor deal
literally within
10 minutes.
What I'm having
a problem with is,
you both have successful
real jobs, okay?
This is a side hustle
that's done very well.
No, no, no, this is not
a side hustle.
Their real job
is the side hustle.
Just 'cause we have
successful jobs doesn't mean
that that's our passion.
Okay, let me put it
to you this way ‐‐
"Hi. I'd like to speak
to the CEO of my spice company."
"I'm sorry.
He's seeing a patient."
"Okay, how about
the other guy?"
"I'm sorry.
He's being an engineer."
To me, you're
all over the map.
Focus, baby. Focus.
That's what I invest in.
You don't have it.
I'm out.
♪♪
You scare me a little
because you have six SKUs here.
You want to come out
with chicken.
You don't know
your challenges
in the other market
you're gonna go into.
You are not working
on this full time.
I just don't see me
getting back the investment.
I think there's gonna be
a lot of hurdles.
Looks like you're
gonna figure it out, hopefully,
in six or seven years.
I just think that's
too long for me, so I'm out.
♪♪
What would you use
the $250,000 for?
So, part of the money is
going to go into development
for our
plant‐based chicken.
This is obviously
just a prototype,
so we need to be able
to get the packaging down.
The second investment is,
we want to be able to launch
our chicken salt lines
into food services spaces.
We've already gotten,
right now, two offers
from one of the
largest restaurant and
entertainment chains
that wants to utilize
our seasoning
for some of their custom
recipes, which is gonna be
six‐figure contracts
from just that one alone.
You guys have enough energy
for 10 entrepreneurs
as a part‐time job.
[ Laughing ] Yeah.
I love the fact that
you're squeezing this in
over your regular jobs.
You've almost made them
part‐time instead.
I have no doubt in my mind
you're gonna succeed.
Thank you.        Thank you.
And if I could offer
one thing I might be able to do,
is slow you down a little bit
on some of your choices.
You're all over the board,
and I love it,
but I want more skin
in the game.
I'm going to
give you the $250,000,
but I want 33%.
♪♪
Narrator:
Two Sharks are out.
Khasha and Maynard have an offer
on the table from Barbara
for their vegan chicken salt
company, JADA Spices.
I'm going to
give you the $250,000,
but I want 33%.
♪♪
Spices and salts
are incredibly tough.
Yes.
You already know that,
right?
You've got a little angle,
and you've made it work for you,
but now you're taking
on vegan chicken,
which is
incredibly difficult.
Trying to combine
those two ‐‐
I don't care if you all
have other jobs.
Just trying
to combine those two ‐‐
you know, working
80 hours a week just on that
is going to be
very difficult.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
Okay.
Barbara?
I will share with you
what I think.
The great thing
about America
and being an entrepreneur
is that at any time,
you can take your destiny
into your own hands
and lead your own life
and create a business,
and that's freedom.
Yes.
Sounds like
an offer is coming.
I love the chicken.
The salts are good, but it's a
very competitive market.
John: If she doesn't give
you an offer, it's gonna
get tough with Barbara.
I like the chicken...
You maybe need to
think about that.
...but it's not
there yet, you know?
That's the problem for me,
is it's just in R&D stages.
If you'd had that
further along,
for me, that's
your winner, your hero.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
♪♪
I am ‐‐ you know,
I'm so nervous for you guys
because I've noticed you haven't
answered Barbara at all,
and, generally, people
just lose deals at this point.
Barbara, we walked in here
with you as our number 1.
I'm not so sure
I believe you right now.
Barbara, so, look,
would you do 28%
plus free skin exams
yearly...
[ Laughter ]
Free ‐‐
what is he saying?
Skin exams.
I love it!
Do you know ‐‐
unfortunately for me,
I have so much Botox
in my face, I'm totally full.
[ Laughter ]
I don't even need it.
No, I'd have to stay
with the 33%.
I'll tell you why ‐‐
because when I have an opinion,
I want to be heard ‐‐
not out of respect,
but because
I'm a third partner.
♪♪
What are you
gonna do, guys?
[ Sighs ]
[ Both whispering ]
♪♪
We're gonna take it.
We'll take your
offer, Barbara.
[ Applause ]
Yes!
Air hug. [ Laughs ]
Cuban:
Congratulations, guys.
I can't believe these guys
didn't make you an offer.
I can't wait to rub it
in their face.
We're gonna take over
the world, yes.
Okay, great.
Thank you
so much, Barbara.
Thank you, guys.
Appreciate it.
Barbara, for sure,
was our number 1
when coming
on this show
because she's invested
in the most food businesses,
and we're trying to make
vegan chicken salt
and turmeric salt
a household name,
so we're right on the way
to do that right now.
Hey, dude, dude, we just
signed a deal on "Shark Tank."
That's crazy.
Oh, my G‐‐ [ Laughs ]
♪♪
Narrator: In season 11,
Sarah Paiji Yoo and Syed Naqvi
made a deal with Kevin O'Leary
for their eco‐friendly cleaning
products company, Blueland.
We are launching in
a big‐box national retailer
at the beginning
of next year.
Done.
Narrator: Let's catch up
with them now.
Just one week after airing,
Kevin brought us on QVC,
and it was
a total "Pinch me" moment.
That's the magic,
right there.
Yoo:
We did $250,000 in sales.
It was bananas.
It's only been
12 months since "Shark Tank,"
and we've already done over
$15 million in sales.
Naqvi:
Blueland now has eliminated
1 billion cleaning bottles
and 5 million pounds
of carbon dioxide.
The pandemic has changed
the physical retail landscape,
so we've decided to hold off
on a retail launch
and double down
on our online sales.
So much of your strategy
when you came on "Shark Tank"
was rolling it out
to the large, big‐box retailers,
and they just disappeared
off the horizon.
O'Leary: What happened because
of this pandemic in America,
it forced us to go digital.
Every company has started
a new strategy
on how to get direct
to their customers.
We shot commercials,
social media ‐‐
everything we could to tell
the Blueland story,
and, wow, did it work.
When we come out of
this pandemic, that's
not gonna change.
We've accelerated
the digitization
of the American economy
by five years.
This is a whole new America,
and it's a really good one.
Keep selling direct
and keep telling the story.
Every piston is firing
on this business.
This is
absolutely fantastic.
Yoo: "Shark Tank" and Kevin
has enabled us
to reach a nationwide audience,
spread our message,
and have such a positive
impact on the environment.
As a mom, I started Blueland
really for my son
and for future generations.
It's been so gratifying to see
that people do really care
and want to make a change
in their lives
and see a better future.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a way to
make gift‐giving more special.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Hey, Sharks!
I'm Jordan!
And I'm Liz!
We're a mom‐and‐son team
from Newton, Massachusetts,
and we're here
seeking $200,000
for 8% equity
in our company.
Sharks, if you couldn't tell,
we're pretty close.
And our family
loves a celebration.
Everyone knows a party without
a cake is no party at all.
But there hasn't been
much innovation with cakes.
Both: Until now!
Introducing Surprise Cake!
With our reusable,
patented popping stand,
you can now hide gifts
inside cakes that ‐‐
Jordan, how can they
take us seriously?
We're in a cake.
You're right, Mom.
Let's get out of here.
♪♪
[ Laughs ]
Okay. Much better.
Mom, show 'em
what you got.
Alright.
Here goes everything.
Do it up for birthdays...
for all ages...
[ Laughter ]
...gender reveals...
♪♪
...holidays...
or even...
pop the question.
The pop‐abilities
are endless.
Greiner: [ Laughs ]
Our revolutionary product
has reinvented
the ultimate party traditions,
taking cake and gift‐giving
to the next level.
So, tell us...
Both: Who wants a piece
of Surprise Cake?
In front of you are
your own Surprise Cakes.
Please put
your party hats on.
Sure enough.
Greiner: [ Laughs ]
And on the
count of three,
pull the ring
to reveal your surprises.
Both: One, two, three!
Surprise!
[ Laughter ]
You can just pull it off,
and it comes right off.
Oh! Wow.
Ahhh!
John: Oh, this is cool.
I got a watch
with a picture
of an extremely handsome
and debonair fellow on it.
What a coincidence.
[ Laughs ]
I got my
favorite gift ‐‐ cash.
More incredibly exciting,
handsome socks.
Jordan: Yep, you all have
custom gifts.
I'm not gonna say
what I got.
How'd you come up
with this crazy idea?
The night before my
daughter's 12th birthday,
I actually had a dream
that I hid her birthday present
inside of her
birthday cake.
The next day,
I did just that,
and as she was
blowing out her candles,
I called her phone,
and the cake rang.
Everybody loved it.
Whoa! Great idea.
And I knew in that moment
that this could be
a great business ‐‐
hiding gifts in cake.
And then, as I was getting ready
to start the business,
I hit a roadblock known
as the Kinder Egg Law,
Oh.
which prohibits putting
non‐edible objects
inside of
confectionery products.
But after giving it some
thought, it occurred to me
that if instead of
putting the gifts
directly into the cake,
you place them in a cake stand,
problem is solved.
What are your backgrounds?
Like, what do you do?
In my previous life,
I was a lawyer.
I actually worked for the
Department of Correction
in Massachusetts.
Kevin, run.
And what about you?
What do you do?
Okay, so, I graduated
from college 2 1/2 years ago
as an industrial engineer.
So, did you design this?
We've worked with
a product designer
who is an expert in design
for manufacturing.
It took us
almost three years
to get it to this point
where it's at now.
So, do you have
a patent on this?
We have
a utility patent.
It's fully approved
in the United States.
We've filed internationally,
in the EU, Canada, Australia.
Just curious what comes
in the products,
'cause we have this
great cake here, but ‐‐
So, up until now, we've been
selling the popping cake stand,
which is the cake stand
that the cake is on,
but one of the big
reasons we're here
is because we're looking
to scale this business
into a one‐stop shop
for Surprise Cakes.
What that's gonna include is,
of course, the popping stand,
the cakes, and also,
the gifts to go inside.
The baked cake?
A baked cake.
A baked cake, yes.
Okay, now, hold on there,
Baba Looey.
Cuban: Wonder what
you're gonna talk about.
What are you gonna
talk about, Kevin?
I want to talk about the cake
industry, 'cause I'm in it...
Please do.
...and I've been in it
for almost 10 years.
They are completely
different businesses,
and you should
really reconsider,
because what you're
selling is a product
that has no spoilage,
doesn't have
a shelf‐life issue.
Cakes have all kinds of
issues around their freshness,
when they're shipped,
how they're shipped.
Why would you want to
do that to yourself?
Liz: Our customers keep
asking for it,
so we thought this would
be a way to go, but ‐‐
Cuban: Let me just
tell you something.
Listening to your customers
is way overrated.
The job of a customer
is just to enjoy ‐‐
not to predict,
not to understand your business,
not to give you guidelines
on where to go ‐‐
just to enjoy
your product or service.
What happened to "The customer
is always right," Mark?
Yeah, that's wrong.
[ Laughter ]
One thing I want to ask you,
though ‐‐ my guess is,
the reason you're deciding
to go into the cake business
is 'cause you're not selling
enough stands without a cake.
Can you tell us
what your sales are there?
Jordan: Yeah, absolutely.
So, we started
2 1/2 years ago.
We launched in
the summer of 2018.
In that first
five months in business,
we did just
$10,000 in sales.
2019, we did
$280,000 in sales,
and year to date, we've done
$550,000 in sales.
Good for you.
Congratulations.
Our run rate is projected
to be $900,000.
So, you think you're gonna
end the year at $900,000?
Yeah.
What's your profit on that?
We're gonna net $50,000.
$50,000?
But why so little?
I don't see
where you guys ‐‐
We have 3 1/2 full‐time
employees right now
that we're
paying salary to.
And how much do you sell it for?
How much is it?
The popping cake stand
alone is $36.99.
Plus, we charge
$7.99 for shipping.
The landed cost of
the popping stand is $8.
Okay, 'cause
you're not gonna
sell too many of these
again to anybody.
You're gonna
sell them once, right?
No, 'cause they have
more than one kid.
I guess you could sell ‐‐
you could reuse it, right?
Use it again and again.
You could reuse it, but that's
where the gift pods come in.
We want to sell gift pods
for every occasion, every theme.
Liz: Exactly ‐‐
curated gift pods.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Curated gift pods?
Yes.
You mean, you want to suggest
what the gift is
that I should give
to my kid?
Exactly.
Another bad idea, but...
Another really bad idea.
Okay, guys, look ‐‐
there are certain horrible
mistakes that companies make.
You guys are drowning
in your revenue attempts.
So many companies
get so amped up.
You hit $100,000 in sales.
[ Exhales sharply ]
You hit $500,000 in sales.
Now you're on a mission to hit
a million, then $2 million,
and you're trying to come up
with all these ways
just to grow that top line
because it's almost like
an ego boost,
as opposed to
the bottom line.
You're chasing revenue
and not chasing profits,
and so for those reasons,
I'm out.
Thank you.
Thanks for that advice.
I'm gonna go back
to my concept ‐‐
Before you go back, could you
straighten out your hat?
It's driving me crazy.
It makes you look weird.
I think it's so funny.
This is how I wear it.
Okay.
You wear your birthday hat the
way you wear your birthday hat.
Okay, fine.
So, I think there's
a healthy balance
on when your customer's
telling you what you need
and then, yes,
drowning in opportunity.
But, you know,
other people up here
know baked goods better than me,
so I'm out.
Thank you, Daymond.
Thank you so much.
Corcoran: You know, Jordan,
you have a winner on your hands.
With that amount of sales,
you should be turning
a much bigger profit.
You have
a successful company ‐‐
one moment ‐‐
but you haven't figured out
how to get money out of it,
so I'm out.
Okay. Thank you
for that advice.
Thank you.
Look, there's nothing
wrong with this,
and you're selling fun,
and you've got a little work
ahead of you,
but the cake idea
freaked me out ‐‐
but that's only 'cause
I'm in the business.
I mean, I forbid you
to do that.
I'm out.
Greiner:
So, I love the idea.
I think this can become
family tradition for people.
Exactly.
It already has.
I think every New Year's ‐‐
money inside or whatever.
Exactly.
But you came in
asking for $200,000 for 8%.
You valued it so high.
We'll work on the
valuation with you.
We'd love to do that.
Make an offer to her.
John: You can counter.
♪♪
Um, would you...
do the $200,000
for 12%?
Ugh.
Ooooooh.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
♪♪
Thanks so much
for your time.
Thank you.     Thank you.
Thank you.            Thank you.
Bye‐bye.
♪♪
Jordan: The Sharks disagree
with our vision
for a one‐stop shop
for Surprise Cake.
We didn't agree.
We're gonna push ahead,
and I know we're gonna do well.
And they're gonna
really regret it.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next into the Tank is a way
to make your holiday meals
more exciting.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name's Lance Burney.
And I'm Kim Burney.
We're from Sanford, Florida,
seeking $100,000
for a 20% equity stake
in our company.
And we've created
a fun new twist
on a family tradition.
We love entertaining
our family and friends,
especially during
the holidays.
This year, instead of
cutting the turkey
with the same old
boring knife,
why not wow your family
and friends with...
[ Whirring ]
Both: ...The Mighty Carver!
[ Laughter ]
Gosh.
The Mighty Carver is
an electric carving knife
that looks, sounds,
and feels like a chainsaw.
Your family and friends
will love it ‐‐
guaranteed to put a smile
on their face.
Not only is it fun,
but it cuts really well.
[ Whirring ]
‐[ Laughs ]
‐That's great.
‐Wow.
‐Listen.
♪♪
Wow.
And it's just not
for turkey.
It has other uses,
as well.
You can use it
on pineapples.
on cantaloupes...
and bread.
My personal favorite
is the morning bagel.
So, this year, be the life
of the party.
Create fun family memories
with The Mighty Carver.
[ Laughs ]
Mark, would you like
to come up and give it a try?
Sure! Why not?
Whoa.
What a man, what a man.
A man and his chainsaw.
[ Chuckles ]
Lance: There's a cutting
accessory down there, too,
if you want to
get fun with it.
Greiner: Oh!
Now we're talking!
[ Laughter ]
Nice. [ Laughs ]
And I would start
with the bre‐‐
Bwuah‐ha‐ha‐ha‐ha!
[ Laughs ]
[ Whirring ]
This is actually really cool
and really easy.
And the actual handle
gives you leverage
for when you're cutting.
Yeah, it really is.
And when you screw up
like I did, bam.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
John: How'd you come up
with this idea?
So, we had
Thanksgiving dinner,
and usually, growing up,
my grandfather cut the turkey.
He's no longer with us.
Somebody has to carry on
this great tradition.
And I tried to figure out,
"Is it Dad?
Is it my husband?
Is it my brother?"
So, my guys love chainsaws
and power tools.
They're just
power tool freaks.
And that's when
I thought, "Wow,
if this was a power tool,
they'd all be fighting over it."
[ Laughter ]
Greiner:
So this was your idea?
Yes.
From start to finish.
Is there any way to
have a childproof lock
or anything like that?
Because that'd be
my greatest fear ‐‐
my 11‐year‐old would grab it
and go Jason on everything.
Well,
you got to remember, too,
that they've been around
for a long time.
So you lock up
your regular knives ‐‐
Well, no,
I get that, right?
But it doesn't look
as enticing as this.
You'd want to put it up
and put it in a safe place
in the cabinets
and everywhere else.
Where are you selling
these primarily?
So, we went to the International
Housewares Show last March,
and we picked up some big
resellers right off the bat ‐‐
Sharper Image, Grommet,
Ace Hardware.
In the stores?
The physical retailers?
We just got our purchase orders
while we were here for that.
So, guys, this is very easy
to demonstrate visually.
And you could sell
direct‐to‐customer, full margin.
Yes.
Why aren't you
doing more of that?
That's what our plan is.
Our goal is to get ‐‐
We got kind of skewed toward
the resellers right now.
Like, 90% of our business
is with resellers.
I need to get that back to
buying direct to the consumer
off of our website,
'cause right now,
we're splitting the money
with everybody.
Right, right, right.
I'd rather bring it
back our way.
Alright. Break down
the numbers for me.
So, we've sold
8,500 units.
And in how many
months was that?
The past 12 months.
12 months.
What was the total
sales figure?
$163,000 last year.
We've sold $41,000
year‐to‐date.
So, what does it cost you
to manufacture,
and what do you
sell it for?
Alright, so, it's $20
landed here in the U. S.
We sell them
for $69 to $89 retail.
What does a typical
electric knife sell for?
Just a regular, plain
electric knife?
I mean, if a chef
puts their name on it,
it could be $169,
but you can get the
cheapest one at a box store
for maybe 19, 20 bucks.
Do you have a patent
or any type of coverage on it?
Yes, we have a design patent
and a Chinese patent.
And it's pretty broad.
Anybody that tries
to make anything
that looks like a chainsaw
on an electric knife ‐‐
That's all you need.
Yeah, that's all you need.
Okay, it's very demonstrable.
I'm making the assumption,
with the right digital buy
and a 59‐second video,
you could sell a ton of these
at Thanksgiving.
Yeah.
Greiner:
Have you done that?
Have you done any videos
or digital marketing?
Mm‐hmm.
You did $41,000 this year
and $163,000 last year?
So, what part of that came
from those digital ads?
10%.
10%?
Mm‐hmm.
That's all?
Why do you think
they didn't work better?
We were early. We were doing
some marketing early.
A lot of this is
showing up organically.
Like, The Wall Street Journal
did an article on us.
We sold 300 the next day.
When did you run those ads?
What time of year?
That was November 17th.
That next Monday,
Kim and I flew back
from a dance competition
and shipped out 300.
What dance competition?
You were dancing?
We're ballroom dancers.
You are?
What?!
You are living
the best life ever.
[ Laughter ]
Guys, guys,
I'm interested in this,
'cause it kind of fits
into my Chef Wonderful world,
and I could actually get
behind it, shoot some videos.
I've got three studios
I shoot commercials in.
I'll do the deal ‐‐
$100,000 for 33.3%
You know, three amigos.
I want to be a third partner.
♪♪
John: Wait a minute.
You know, I use an electric
knife often for fishing,
and then I use another one
inside the house.
I like it.
I think you guys are fun.
I use electric knives
all the time.
So I'll give you $100,000
for 27.5%.
Wow.
Unfortunately,
you're not Chef Wonderful.
Very lucky about that.
Thank God.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you.
Barbara, did we answer
all your questions?
I'm just trying to think
of how I could outwit
these two other Sharks
and take this deal,
so I'm gonna be quiet
for a minute.
I want to get Daddy Big Bucks
out of the way over here.
[ Laughs ]
O'Leary:
What are you doing, Lori?
I'm listening to Mark.
Why is everybody
waiting on me?
Guys, you know what?
Well, you're always
waiting on us.
If you do it right now,
I'll do the $100,000 for 25%,
but you got to say yes
right now.
Ooh.
Corcoran:
Wait, wait, wait.
Don't be so fast.
Relax.
You know what happens
after we keep dancing around?
It could go.
We've cram‐coursed 11 seasons,
so we know. [ Laughs ]
25% right now ‐‐
$100,000.
Barbara.
How about 22?
25.
Um...
I'm offering you 25%
for $100,000.
That's five points over
what you asked for.
And he's really into it.
I don't care about it.
I just want to take the deal.
Yeah.
Yes or no?
Guys, do you want to
make an offer?
You're about to
lose the deal.
You know what? Hold it. No,
we're not gonna lose the deal.
Lookit over here.
We have something to say here.
He's gonna walk,
you guys.
Going once.
5...4...3...
We want to give you
the same offer ‐‐
Going twice.
Wait, wait, wait.
He loves it.
He's a fisherman.
You ready?
No!
Got it!
No!!
Kim said yes.
Oh, no!
She's the boss.
Thank you, guys.
Kim ‐‐ Oh, no!
Dance out! Dance out!
Thank you. We will.
We'll dance out.
Yes, dance out!
John: There you go.
Lance:
We were hearing Mark and Barbara
talking in the background,
but then
when Lori started saying,
"He's serious. He's a fisherman.
You should do the deal,"
I was like, "Okay,
we need to do the deal."
And Kim pulled the trigger, and
it's a done deal. We're happy.
Very happy with Daymond.
You dirty dog, Daymond!
You dirty dog!
O'Leary:
You waited too long, Barbara.
It just shows you ‐‐
you snooze, you lose.
You're squawking like a chicken.
The deal just dances out.
Oh, my God.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is a simple product
using a space‐age material.
♪♪
[ Rapping ] ♪ I gotta be honest,
I didn't come here to rap ♪
♪ Came to talk about my
business, as a matter of fact ♪
♪ Might start a feeding frenzy
as I spit on this track ♪
♪ So I ask all the Sharks,
"Sit back and relax" ♪
♪ Flipstik is the brand ♪
♪ If you already heard about it,
raise your hand ♪
♪ It's a kickstand on demand ♪
♪ With Flipstik, gravity is
under your command ♪
♪ Let me repeat
for those who missed it ♪
♪ To any flat surface,
your phone will stick ♪
♪ Get it wet, but the
stickiness will persist ♪
♪ Tell ya how I thought it up
if time permits ♪
♪ Flipstik is the brand ♪
♪ If you already heard about it,
raise your hand ♪
Heeeeeey!
♪ It's a kickstand
on demand ♪
♪ With Flipstik, gravity is
under your command ♪
♪ In summary, I came
to "Shark Tank" for a band ♪
♪ So I could put Flipstik
in everybody's hand ♪
♪ Sharks,
give the kid a chance ♪
♪ I'll deliver ROI
on yo' 100 grand ♪
My name is Akeem Shannon.
St. Louis, Missouri,
is where I kick it.
Whoo! Great job!
I'm seeking
a $100,000 investment
for a 20% stake
in my business, Flipstik.
I got to say, that rap was
one of the best raps
we've ever seen
on this stage.
Best rap on
"Shark Tank" ever.
So, who's ready
to see a demo?
Yeah!
Yes, sir.
Awesome.
This is Flipstik.
Flipstik is
a paper‐thin device
that goes on the back
of your phone.
It comes in over 70 different
designs and colors,
and with a simple flip,
you can sit it down
on any flat surface.
But the magic really starts
when you reveal
our synthetic CT adhesive
Based off the foot
of a gecko,
essentially, it lets you
stick your phone anywhere.
Cool.
And when I say "stick,"
I mean it really sticks.
Like, this is not
going anywhere
until you give it
a little twist,
Wow.
Brilliant.
and it comes off
without damaging the surfaces.
But it's not just glass.
Check out this textured
tile surface here.
Flipstik even sticks here
just as well.
And the great thing is,
you can use it in the kitchen
or in the bath.
But it's not just
tile or glass.
Whether it's metal, vinyl,
Flipstik goes where you are.
Check this out.
I have three of the dirtiest
household items here, right?
I have hair, I got sand,
and I got my mama's
homemade spaghetti
straight from the can.
Now, we're gonna
get this Flipstik
really dirty, here.
So we're gonna get
a little hair going on there.
Greiner: Ew.
How about a little
sand action here?
Greiner: [ Groans ]
And we got to get
a little bit...
Mama! Mama!
...of spaghetti.
Not the spaghetti!
This...
This ain't sticking
to nothing, alright?
So, check this out.
Watch as we wipe away
all the dirt and grit
and sand from this Flipstik.
Nice and clean.
And so, who thinks
it's gonna stick?
I do.
[ Laughs ]
I have a lot
of believers here.
Cuban: Hey!
Yay! Whoo‐hoo!
And that, in a nutshell,
is Flipstik.
Any questions?
Do you have a patent?
A design patent?
So, I do have a patent.
In fact, let me just tell you
a little bit about my story.
Yeah.
So, it all started
when I was going to college
and I had
a full‐tuition scholarship.
I went to Howard University
in Washington, D. C.
Nice.
I went there,
and I lost my scholarship
in the first year.
Greiner: Why?
Why?
It was a little bit
of partying.
of depression, to be honest.
Aww.     Aww.
It was
the hardest phone call
I ever had to make
to my parents
because they sacrificed
everything
to get me to this point,
and I felt like I threw it away,
to be honest.
And I told myself,
"I got to prove to my parents,
'Hey, you did not waste
all of your savings,
your life energy on me.'"
So I got to work.
I ended up starting
in the cellphone industry
at a major retailer ‐‐
Sprint ‐‐
and I was one of the
top salespeople there.
I was making $30,000 a year.
Then I got recruited
to come work for Verizon
on their business side,
and next thing I know,
I'm making $60,000,
$70,000, $80,000 a year.
By the time my friends
graduated, I was making more
than any of them were making
coming out of college.
But not only that,
I was the number 1 rep
at a Fortune 500 company,
and eventually,
I ended up at one of the biggest
financial tech companies
in the world ‐‐ Square.
But I'm meeting
all these entrepreneurs,,
and I'm talking to them.
I'm helping with their business.
I'm helping with marketing.
And it's just like, "Man,
if these guys can do it,
like, I got to do this.
Like, I got to quit."
My mom was not happy,
but this time, I was like,
"I have to go out on my own."
So, it's 3:00 A. M.
My uncle calls me.
My uncle's an engineer at NASA,
and he's telling me about
this project he's working on
called the Space Launch System.
And he ends up just talking
about how he's working through
some stuff, and he's gonna
use this adhesive.
Wait, your uncle called you
at 3:00 A. M.?
My uncle always calls
at 3:00 A. M.
because that's
the time he's up.
[ Laughter ]
He calls me 3:00 A. M.,
we're talking, and I'm like,
"Man, this adhesive
sounds interesting.
You know what? This could work
on a cellphone."
So I started doing research.
I get on YouTube.
I teach myself
to write a patent,
to write a trademark,
and I launch
my Kickstarter campaign.
And that's how
I got here today.
This film is not
proprietary, right?
That's correct.
I can buy
rolls of this myself.
That's correct.
So, the difference
is the design.
So we actually have filed
for a utility patent,
and it's for having
a double‐sided adhesive
on the phone
and the flap cover.
What does it cost to make,
and what do you sell them for?
On average, it costs us
58 cents to make.
We sell these for $15.
Whoa.
However, often,
we sell them in bundles,
so it's one for $15,
two for $25, or three for $30.
Those are some margins
right there.
You got to be
killing it.
What are your
total sales to date?
Our total sales to date is
$115,000 in about 2 1/2 years.
Akeem, something's not
adding up. Your sales suck.
$115,000 over two years.
You've been
the number 1 salesperson
everywhere you've gone.
You know 115K is awful.
Right? For real.
60% of our business
is retail,
and I don't mean
online retail.
I mean brick‐and‐mortar
retail business.
Where?
So, I operate
a network of kiosks,
and we do
a number of events.
Retail was
completely eliminated.
You recognize the big miss here
is you're not selling direct.
'Cause your margins
are crazy.
Yes. Absolutely.
I'm gonna put an offer
out there, okay?
'Cause I think this is
absolutely fantastic.
No, you need to tell me
about competition...
Wait, wait. Let me just ‐‐
You don't need Lori
for any of this.
Yes, he does. He needs me
way more than you.
I really want to tell Lori
about competition, 'cause
this is actually huge.
Listen, you got to
stop selling sometimes
to let the offers start
coming in, right?
Competition.
Look, I like the deal.
Valuation's not crazy.
I'll give you $100,000
for 20% ‐‐
exactly what you want.
♪♪
So, tell me about
your competition.
♪♪
Our competition ‐‐
and you're gonna like this, too,
Mr. Wonderful ‐‐
our competition is
the doorknob on the phone.
I'm sure you guys all know
what I'm talking about.
It's PopSocket.
But PopSocket doesn't
stick to surfaces.
Do any others have
that material on the back
where you can stick it
to any surface?
None, and that's
what our patent is.
I made you an offer ‐‐
exactly what you wanted.
Corcoran: And I would like
to address that offer,
You don't like it?
if I might, Akeem.
You know, you've got such
a magnetic personality...
Thank you.
...and you are
a superstar salesman.
But I don't think
you're gonna succeed
unless you get yourself
a working partner.
I'm surprised you're getting
an offer from Kevin, honestly.
I don't think you're gonna make
a hit run on this at all,
so I'm out, sadly.
Thank you, Barbara.
John: So, here's where
I'm at, Akeem.
I have a similar company.
It doesn't make the same claims
you have, but, you know,
it's called LoveHandle,
and it stops you from
dropping the phone
as well as, you know ‐‐
it can stand up as well.
I think they will be
somewhat of a competitor,
so I'm out.
I understand.
Thank you, Daymond, truly.
Akeem, how much
did you sell last month?
So, yeah, so, last month,
it was pretty low.
I mean, we're looking
at $1,500.
$1,500.
Yeah.
That's it?
I tell you something ‐‐
I know what you need.
I think you need me.
The name of the game
with this product ‐‐
everything about it
is the visual,
and I've spent 20 years creating
over thousands of videos
that tell you
within 10 seconds
what a product is
and why you should buy it.
And I actually
really like ‐‐
O'Leary: Akeem, I'm gonna
make it easy for you.
I'm gonna make
it easy for you.
I made you an offer ‐‐
exactly what you wanted ‐‐
before you told me that
you only sold $1,500,
so, clearly, nothing's
working digitally for you.
I'm not saying
Lori can't do it,
but I'm gonna make it easy.
When I make an offer
on "Shark Tank,"
I am the only
Mr. Wonderful,
and it's exactly
what you wanted.
You should have taken it.
Now you only have one Shark.
I'm out.
♪♪
Narrator:
Three Sharks are out.
Akeem had one offer
on the table from Kevin
offering him exactly
what he came in seeking,
but his hesitation and new
information about his low sales
for his phone accessory,
Flipstik,
has caused Kevin to drop out.
I'm gonna make it easy.
I'm out.
♪♪
Greiner: Akeem,
I'm a product person,
and I've sold over
1,000 successful products.
So here's my offer.
I'm gonna give you
the $100,000,
but I want 25%.
Lori, you understand
you're giving him a
valuation of $400,000.
He did $1,500
in sales last month.
That's primarily
due to COVID, to be fair.
Greiner: Wait, wait.
Here's the thing.
Two of our revenue
channels were cut.
Sometimes, when an entrepreneur
comes in here,
I'm just asking you
if you're aware.
I know what I can do.
♪♪
Mark Cuban is in.
See what he thinks.
Well, I mean, you can respond
to Lori any way you want.
I would like
to respond to Lori.
Thank you. Like,
that's an incredible offer.
I know your history.
It's flawless.
I do feel like I came with
a very, very fair offer,
Wow.
at $100,000 for 20%.
Are you crazy?
Greiner: Here's what
I can tell you.
I don't have to prove myself
because I know you're smart,
but the one thing
you don't know
is what it takes to ‐‐
beyond retail.
You have to
put retail aside,
Lori, I ‐‐
because it's not
happening right now.
Lori, I forbid you
to keep convincing him ‐‐
Stop interrupting Lori.
She's got a great pitch here.
Come on! 5%?
Stop interrupting her.
You need to go digital.
♪♪
So, I gave you my offer.
Don't pass that by.
You'd be out of your mind.
She's the ideal partner
for you.
The ideal partner.
I don't know about that.
Yeah, I don't know about that.
♪♪
I think you are
the ideal partner.
Honestly, Mark has been
a little quiet here.
Well, if she's the ideal
partner, there's no ‐‐
So I'm taking
the deal with Lori.
Whoo!
Yes!
Yes! We're gonna
blow these up.
Smart man. Smart man.
These are fabulous.
You are one of
the luckiest people
I've ever seen
in my life.
[ Laughs ]
Listen, thank you all
and have a great
rest of the day.
Yeah! [ Laughs ]
I chose not to listen
to Mark's offer
because I didn't want to
risk Lori going out.
She's my dream Shark,
and that's who I wanted,
so I had to take
the deal on the table.
This isn't
an in‐store item.
To me, this is all online
and all video.
It's a $5.99 item.
I can do a video on this
showing how this works
on all those different surfaces
within 10 seconds,
and that's why
he needed me.
I'm happy he landed with you.
Perfect partner.
Thanks.
♪♪